You want to talk about
what the former president is doing,
both on the legal side
and also the political side.
And so both of those, we want to bring in
CNN reporter Daniel Dale to fact check
some of the claims made by the former
president last night
when addressing the crowd at Bedminster.
Daniel Trump claimed
that the Espionage Act
shouldn't be applied in this case.
Take a listen.
Charging a former president
of the United States
under the Espionage Act of 1917
wasn't meant for this The Espionage Act
has been used to go after traitors
and spies.
It has nothing to do
with a former president legally
keeping his own documents
All right, Daniel,
there's the
former president's contention.
What are the facts?
So two big problems of fact here.
First of all,
these are not his own documents.
They are the legal property
of the federal government.
Second of all, though,
this idea that the Espionage Act
is only meant for traitors
and spies is just not true.
Of course,
there are provisions of the Espionage Act
that target traitors and spies,
but there's
also the provision under which Trump
and many people
before him have been charged.
It's known as seven 93.
And it makes it a crime
to willfully retain
national defense information
and refuse
to deliver it to the United States.
Nothing in that provision
requires you to be a spy
to to do any classic espionage,
to even deliver the information
to anyone.
And as an example,
you can go back
and look at another indictment,
the 2017 indictment
of a former NSA contractor
named Harold Martin.
He was accused of taking a whole bunch
of classified information
and just keeping it in his car
and his house.
He was never accused in court
of giving it to anyone of being a spy.
He was essentially portrayed
as a kind of hoarder.
He ended up pleaded guilty.
So not a spy.
This provision was applied
and he was convicted and sentenced.
One other thing
that's so interesting
is that the former president
made the point
that instead of the Espionage Act,
the law that should be applied
here is the Presidential Records Act,
which actually isn't
part of the indictment. Listen to this.
Threatening
me with 400 years in prison
for possessing my own
presidential papers,
which just about every other
president has done
is one of the most outrageous and vicious
legal theories
ever put forward
in an American court of law.
As president the law that applies to
this case is not the Espionage Act,
but very simply,
the Presidential Records Act,
which is not even mentioned
in this ridiculous 44 page indictment
under the Presidential Records Act,
which is civil, not criminal.
I had every right
to have these documents.
Putting aside the fact
that that's not even in the indictment,
if it were.
Does that does appear
absolve him of any of this?
It it does.
And the idea
that the Presidential Records
Act absolves former
President Trump here is like upside down
bizarro world stuff.
That law, Poppy, is unequivocal.
It says that all official records
from a presidency
are the property
of the federal government,
the National Archives.
The moment
that President leaves office,
as one expert
put it to me,
the fact that former President Trump
violated the Presidential Records Act
does not prevent him from being charged
for also allegedly violating
another law
And I'll add,
there's two other problems of fact
in that quote we just played.
Number one, he's
not actually being threatened
with 400 years in prison.
Federal sentencing
does not work by adding up the maximum
possible sentence for each crime.
So that's not realistic.
And second of all,
it's just not true
that just about every other president
has done what he's done.
No other president
in the Presidential Records Act era
So starting with President
Ronald Reagan has done anything like
take a trove of sensitive
classified documents and refuse
to give them back
to the federal government.
When asked repeatedly to do so
right there
in the willful retention allegation.
Daniel Dale, thank you.
Your fact checks are gold.
We appreciate them.